so this this this attack that happened
this is the crazy thing to cuss out in
um in in medicine okay it started over a
dude who went to a restaurant with a
megaphone and a baseball bat and was
screaming about how Jesus was stolen he
was originally Horus from Egypt and that
the white man stole it he's technically
not wrong
yeah lots of Christianity comes from
paganism Egyptian all religions
everything yeah they're shared mythos
right exactly and so some people argue
it's because all these different
religions are viewing the truth through
a different lens at a different angle
okay
this man happen to argue - Singh yeah so
it's like you know for different parts
of the world you're seeing a similar
thing but you're looking at a different
way so you see different things than
everyone see right right so this guy was
claiming that the white man or whatever
stole Jesus he's not white there it is I
mean Shawn King said it then a guy shows
up with a baseball bat yeah then they
arrest him and then a riot breaks out so
messed up it's like everyone can have a
God and everyone like your relationship
with God is your own you know I'm not
the most religious person but it's like
if I imagine whatever my God would be it
doesn't have to be the same as yours but
I'm not I'm not even concerned is the
same with Jesus it's like if if you
think you you have a relationship with
him whoever it is whatever it is you
know you you choose what that is it's
like man all I see is just hate people
just hatin trying to trying to throw
throw shade it I don't know out anywhere
they can I don't think the issue so much
as the religion is the fact that Shawn
King said Jesus was not white burn it
down yep and then a day later a guy
shows up with a megaphone and a baseball
bat screaming just wasn't white yeah he
was Horace he put that idea and
everyone's head it's like doing then the
cops come in they're like yo you can't
megaphone inside a restaurant with a
baseball bat you're right I mean they
arrested him 200 writers herb you know
these rioters did what they went into a
private condo and we're romping about
they'd surrounded like a tow vehicle hey
man listen you want to talk about what
what might happen fine I think it's it's
it's it's I don't want there to be any
kind of escalation I want things to be
normal again you know it was fun when we
were just talking about Sonic the
Hedgehog and birds of prey and then all
sudden everything went nuts I miss
making fun of birds of prayer yeah well
I'd watch it again just to make fun of
it what but listen man they're going in
private homes
yeah it's beating up democratic
politicians I mean they they should be
worried there's a lot of guns now
everywhere a lot of people got guns this
year I just got a bunch of guns today
yeah finally I was wondering if you're
gonna say it or not oh yeah bunch lots
of guns and so now and I was talking to
some of these guys at the gun shop and I
was like you know six months ago I said
I don't want any guns in my house I do
not want even after someone tried
breaking and I was like you know what
I've thought about it we got we got
local cops they're good dudes they found
us out they were here in a minute I
don't think I want guns in this house
and now it's then kovat happened even I
was like hmm and then nationwide riots
we could hear the helicopters and I was
like five six I'm still waiting for the
sig from from Crowder yeah yeah but
apparently what they were telling me is
that the suppliers are all dried up oh
really
the manufacturers are sold out not smart
though the shops are all getting cleaned
out yeah man this one shop the shelves
are pretty empty really yeah yeah they
have squirt guns they have squirt guns
instead and so I went in there and I was
like Steven crowd I recommended a gun
they're like got it I was like really
what do you have and then they showed me
what they got and then I bought a bunch
of I'll take one of everything please
what I think you know a lot of these
progressives don't understand em when
they're saying like Joe Biden can win
I'm like you know I was asking some of
the guys said what do you think it means
that stores like this are selling out
like they're struggling to get inventory
guns are going nuts first-time buyers
are through the roof yeah what do that
means gonna happen in November Trump's
gonna landslide I think a lot of people
you know everyone says it's you know you
take the red pill and it's like that's
not necessarily going Republican that's
just opening your eyes to the truth and
I don't even honestly that Trump isn't
necessarily Republican you know he's not
he's not he's not a classic Republican
it's interesting you know when you
really look at it all the New York Times
actually did an analysis of the party's
manifestos like their party lines in the
words they use okay and under Donald
Trump
since 2012 he pulled the party ever slow
so slightly to the left nice and and Vox
said that Trump ran as a moderate now
Trump certainly does adopt a lot of the
traditional Republican positions yeah
but he is I mean come on man he's the
first president to support gay marriage
before entering office and not even
Obama did that it's true so so Trump is
slightly to the left no the problem is
the left has gone so far left they think
Trump is far-right yeah so all these
people that are buying guns they might
not be Republican but I they're they're
certainly moving away from this crazy
left that is running rampant through our
country right now it reminds me of this
skate video with rodney mullen and they
have this this cart with a flat steel
top and push it towards him oh yeah and
he stays in the same spot yeah so yeah
so so Ronnie Mullen is pro skateboarder
he alleys stationary and then does what
is I guess simply called a wheelie but
the platform is moving underneath him
and he's staying in the same place it's
cool yeah it's really cool and then I
think he flips out he does a lot of
different tricks it's so just the one
trick right yeah this cool that that
image in my mind is exactly how it feels
here comes the Democratic Party and
you're just staying right where you are
and now you're off yeah so you look at
Donald Trump's and then and then in come
in comes Trump he's like hey I got you
I'm kinda in the middle ya know that's
why I think he's pulling a lot of people
I mean hey I'm not a Republican yeah
look at me I'm in the middle
III do I I'm in the middle I have a lot
of things that I agree with both sides
and I disagree with both sides but I'm
definitely in the middle this is what I
was thinking the other day when I did
that rant it's like I'm talking to these
dudes today who are basically like
Trump's gonna win I'm not worried about
it and I'm like if you if you've been
sitting back while they've been tearing
down statues thinking well I'll vote
November yeah you know look man Trump
wins the left goes insane they burn
everything the ground and you sit there
saying well you know in four years I'll
vote for Trump jr. well you know I was
thinking about that it's like what what
can people do a lot of people have asked
me since yet since the other day they
were like you know Tim Tims
yelling at me because I'm not doing
anything but wailing at you what can I
do what can I do Tim like you know a lot
some of them were getting upset at you
like you know I
and I saw a lot of examples of people
quitting their jobs they did quit but a
decent lost their income and are
searching for new jobs because they they
they aren't they're fed up with it you
know so like what are those people do do
they go out and stand it from the
statues jobless No or do they worry
about where they're gonna get income and
and focus on getting a job which is what
you think an average person would focus
on instead of putting themselves in
harm's way when they aren't even stable
themselves anymore you know because they
made that that choice the price of
freedom is high it's a good point it's
very high it's a price I'm willing to
pay down by the river ten F I'm the only
one so be it but I'm willing to bet that
I'm not but you you were going down by
just quoting Chris Evans from I know but
I'm calling you out what now you were
saying just like you'd go down by the
river if things got got anyone else good
- that's true
but that's so that's the same thing as
just letting people burn the statues now
the interesting thing - no no no like
I'm talking about when you lose and and
you've lost everything and there's
nothing left go but a little mud hut not
by the river now it's funny to me as the
people who have said but Tim I've got a
family it's so much easier for you to
say and I'm like no we're talking about
snot true that's backwards it's easier
for you to say
you have kids it's so much easier for
you to say that you'd be willing to
sacrifice everything for your children
than for me yeah I don't have kids I'm
at least yet so I'm not necessarily
scared for what might the future holds
for my kids if you have kids it's even
your it's easy easier for you to say I
will do everything in my power to ensure
a future for my children you want to
know something interesting we got baby
birds out in the backyard in the deck
man you wanna know something funny it
wasn't funny we let buku out in the deck
okay okay the kitty and he lurks and he
walks over and he walks over to where
the nest is at just underneath the panel
cuz they're on one of the beams and
little tiny and then the robin parent
jumps out and starts screaming knowing
it's going to die because a cat will
kill it it's true and it jumps up
screaming you will not hurt my children
and then the craziest thing happened
like this is a true story happened like
last week
little tiny birds I have no idea what
they were started swoop was like
swooping at me and I was like dying
these birds are coming after
dude and the kiddies sitting on the
ground looking up like get ready to
pounce and I'm like nah now we're gonna
get it look leave the babies alone the
good news is the baby Robins survived
they grew up and they left the nest oh
they're gone i gassed nice but but I saw
that it's like these birds know that by
like it landed on the deck on the on the
post in the corner with with with our
cat sitter just screeching screeching
whoa
and I'm like careful careful Tim no that
was just I know you got a conserve your
voice man but but I'm inspired by that
man yeah yeah that what what's the
difference between that little bird that
has no power whatsoever to stop a human
being in the cat willing to challenge us
to a fight I laughed and I looked at
bucko and I was like that little bird
thinks he can take us he's no he's no
match for a kitty in his human ally and
it's true you know yet he was willing to
sacrifice everything for his children so
listen a lot of people forget that we
are animals we are we are we are a part
of this ecosystem animals we have very
similar thought patterns and desires and
drives but I'll tell you what man those
Robins haven't lost that the this the
the the perseverance the the survival
instinct so get it yeah I think I think
something has happened where people are
now conflating being able to buy a loaf
of bread for your kids with actually
providing for your kids you're right I
get it I get it I don't have kids
I know survival of the fittest almost
doesn't exist anymore it's survival who
has the most money it's but but think
about that same thing what if you what
if your children and your wife what if
you had no access to a city what if you
had to be a real provider going out and
hunting a wild boar living in it it's
like you've been talking about so it's
not understand what they actually have
in this world it's not so much about you
saying I could lose my job and can't
feed my family it's you saying we live
in such luxury I don't want to risk it I
don't want to actually go back to the
days where a boat land on the shores of
the North America and they got off the
boat and they were like bunch of trees
we're home guys and then they jumped off
the boat and we're like set up a camp
and there was no food that was that's
crazy man that mentality is gone that's
the mentality of that little bird saying
like I will mess you up
even if it means I die you will not
touch my babies now it's like these
people are saying
I understand you want to plague the bait
minds of my babies that's okay that's
okay as long as we can have pizza on the
weekends you know it's it's interesting
you're saying that because I've been
thinking I mean we talk about this all
the time just society and you know where
we're at nowadays and I kind of started
talking about you know the loss of of
the masculine male you know and like
traditional you know families and when
you look at animals any animal the alpha
male is the one that procreates the most
that survives that's why that's why
we're still here because alpha males
have been fighting and conquering and
technology and like boom now we're here
and that doesn't exist anymore you know
we don't need the alpha male so the
alpha male is going away and look what's
happening you know look look what a
bunch of men turning into rapists well I
mean sure but it's what's but it's not
that it's society is coddling all of us
yeah we are all losing that because
Society has has let us be comfortable so
it's society's fault as a whole that we
are so comfortable that we're losing the
the need to have an alpha male that to
someone that's gonna you know maintain
that you know survivability they're you
know now it's all medicines now we just
you know medicines make us live longer
oh I can pay for that oh I got cancer
but I could just pay for that if I have
enough money on on Steven krottas
website they posted my rant oh did that
nice yeah and in the comment section cuz
cuz Steven hit me actually he's like hey
we're gonna you know keep some traffic's
gonna let you know you're an was awesome
I was like cool man thanks writer and so
I went and checked it out and I saw the
comments and someone mentioned that it's
easy for Tim to say but we have kids we
got to put food on the table right and
one of the responses because you can go
check this out I think it's still there
was something like we raised our kids
totally normally they went to college in
Oregon and now they've gone insane and
disowned us for supporting for
supporting Trump and so it's like you
want to talk about doing everything
right and giving your kids the food they
need and then they get indoctrinated in
their brains get twisted into jelly
you know and you could have stood up and
stopped it but you were happier just
making sure they had pizza on the table
you know they had their their their
mashed potatoes and gravy in their in
their steak and those are all really
important things I can respect that
yeah food sure but we're facing a
cultural crisis right now where our
founding fathers are being torn from
their base and I'm not talking about you
know because people have tried arguing
about slave owners right what so at
first they started going after the
Confederates statues and they're like
why are we honoring traitors anyway and
I'm like you know I gotta be I got to be
honest I have no I would I would vote in
favor of taking the Confederate itches
down putting in a museum and putting up
a plaque I think it'd be awesome to have
a museum showing all the statues growing
this is our history and and that and
that's my opinion and then you put a
plaque in the space that says like this
was once home to the statue of so-and-so
on this date at this time we decided
that we would put aside you know these
symbols for these reasons to be cool but
then they started going after the
founding fathers and the argument was
slavery and I said well there's there's
no like that you I will absolutely an
always condemn the past the failures of
humanity especially with slavery and
even today the founding fathers created
something truly great so I think you're
you're missing the point here
yeah now they're getting rid of
abolitionists now they're announcing
they're gonna tear down Lincoln it
doesn't make any sense right and it
never will and so you you give them an
inch and they take everything from you
and so these people who think I can just
sit back and say well as long as my kids
have food I'll be okay no it won't they
will come to your house like they did in
Madison where they went to this private
condos they will find your politicians
and beat them and then eventually your
kids are gonna be sitting there you man
these photos are so sad you have this
like normal-looking teenage girl the
smile on her face
wearing regular clothes jeans and a
t-shirt and the next photo was like two
years after college and she's got this
angry scowl on her face one eye is like
bigger than the other and her heads
shaved so you're talking about the
Blasio's daughter yeah not specifically
have you seen have you seen how they
also do these weird snarl faces yeah I
don't it's like they have lost their
minds
yeah and so you want you you think your
children are safe you think you're
saving your children by doing this I'm
sorry man I don't agree do you think
every kid that goes to high score
college is going through that and now
ending up like that no of course well
what do you think the percentage is done
I think it's really small actually a
small percent very small okay so because
I because I just my
another minority group than that they're
just reading the loudest then and this
week II will gets the grease okay and as
we learned from South Park and from
history the people who threaten the
violence for some reason everyone back
bends the knees to them and then they
get what they want and that's what we're
trying to stop we want the rule of law
back we want people to be able to live
and for the for the system to function
properly people have a real chance I
think the people that that aren't like
that don't want violence and are trying
to not be violent yep but are a hundred
percent willing to be violent when that
when it finally comes to their door I
disagree which it well it's not at their
doorstep yet Tim look at the guys look
at the guy at the Macy's okay you saw
that video okay well you all this one
put one example it's like that one
person I'm not gonna let that one person
alright influence what I feel that went
into a private condominium sure and
romped about and no one did anything
about it and they beat the crap out of a
politic politician okay so was he armed
no well what did they meet someone who
was armed no and I think Madison is
Republican isn't it I don't know I don't
know so III agree with you for the most
part yeah sure we're not seeing that yet
you know right but I think people are
going to lock their doors and they're
gonna say please leave me alone I knows
what can happen and when they break down
the door that's too late
see you late at that point now they're
gonna get shot I don't think so
what are you gonna do when someone tries
to break in that's different is it yeah
it is how I'm not the average person
who's cowering I'm the person who
actually stood up and said tear up my
contract right now yeah but they're
they're tearing down the statues right
now they're they're doing it's not you
it's the the whole country now what I'm
saying is I'd be willing to bet in many
areas many rural areas you you will get
a shotgun blast the face if you if you
even walk in their house there's a video
of a guy who drove down the wrong
driveway you see that so and the guys
like he's shot in his car yeah like
sound people man I hear you mm-hmm but
in the suburb as the beginning we're not
seeing it yet this is the beginning I'm
a dude Wisconsin is blue Illinois is
blue
I think Madison's blue right but I think
what you're it is Madison blue I'm
pretty
sure and probably it makes sense
somewhat someone mentioned exactly I'm
gonna so we're familiar with it but
they'll probably probably mention
whether I'll see you guys in the chat
but Madison is very liberal yeah
everyone is in ya the chats yeah pretty
uniform thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you